michael baltimore best known for his
appearances as a barber on season 4 of
90 day fiance happily ever after is
wanted by the u.s marshals for allegedly
murdering his boss kendall jerome cook
according to the law enforcement agency
baltimore has been added to its 15 most
wanted list and is offering up to 25 000
in reward money for information that
leads to his arrest
he's wanted in carlisle pennsylvania
where authorities say the 39 year old is
alleged to have shot and killed cook and
injured another man at the gq barber
shop in carlisle on may 22nd
2021 the same barber shop where a number
of scenes were filmed for the hit tlc
reality show in 2019. if my girl caught
me on a dating site it'd be curtains
it's over
there's no fans or buts about it cause
that's cheating in the scenes that aired
on the show it seemed as though cook and
baltimore enjoyed a friendship
but now the u.s marshal says baltimore
is wanted for assault homicide and
parole violation charges the agency is
working with the carlisle police
department and the middle district of
pennsylvania to capture him
it's been quite a year for former 90 day
stars making news headlines in april 90
day fiance alum caroline twitsky was
allegedly attacked by her boyfriend cole
goldberg in florida according to
multiple reports the talent agent
survived an alleged murder attempt by
goldberg whom she had been dating for a
year
and who can forget this major story back
in february
90 day fiance star jeffrey paschall was
sentenced to 18 years in prison without
the possibility of parole jeffrey was
convicted of kidnapping and assaulting
his ex-fiance the next thing i remember
he was beating me the sentencing came
after a jury found the 44 year old
guilty of aggravated kidnapping domestic
assault and interference with emergency
calls
you